[Music]
too much
information
here we are big ass we're doing
interview okay yes sir let's go first
off okay
bts who bts
who are bts members kim namjoon kim
taehyung
[Music]
who in bts has the deepest boys
next question who bts who joined bts
in order rm is the first
and then suga and jacob and then
jin jungkook jin and chung cook
is the latest who is bts best friend
oh who is media's best friend
bts
has come to my birthday party oh sorry
oh sorry sorry
korean
drivers
[Applause]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
hello i am jin i'm alright my name is
free
i'm group oh yeah i'm jungkook
i'm your hope you're my hope i'm jay oh
hi i'm jimin
hi i'm sugar
[Laughter]
members in bts uh korean age
no global age let's go
i'm 26 i'm 25
25 i'm 23 23 yeah i'm 27
25. oh five two twenty eight twenty oh
wow oh bts learn the english
oh yeah
is taking lessons yeah hobie is taking
lessons
suga is taking lessons and you are
taking no lessons
netflix how can bts sing and dance at
we barely buy our own clothes exactly
louis vuitton the best
disabilities died their hair done
drink coffee oh i love coffee
oh
first is famous bts
oh yeah very very famous
okay
[Laughter]
this video is nice yeah video is very
very nice
no we're great bt is nice
oh no we're a bad boy yeah yeah
i'm a bad boy yeah yeah yeah yes i'm a
bad boy
my turn who bts
who bts who
is bts reader kim namjoon
our leader is very smart and very
very kind oh yeah
that's strong very tasty big
body very handsome
who is bts
[Applause]
very very handsome guy thank you thank
you my bro
okay next question
who is the best dancer in bts
[Music]
oh yeah jean and sugar
does business
playstation yeah yeah nintendo oh ho
xbox it takes two running games sir oh
video game pts watch annie
this is
foreign
yes
[Laughter]
and thanks for watching thank you thank
you okay thank you